l'orangé ou le maire de saint-brès dans
l'hérault bonsoir monsieur joël merci
d'être avec nous en direct par téléphone
sur rtl france vous êtes donc le maire
de saint-brès une commune de près de
4000 habitants dans l'hérault vous avez
déposé ce matin un recours au tribunal
administratif de montpellier pour faire
annuler dans votre commune les résultats
des municipales alors on le précise
puisque c'est assez rare vous avez été
élu vaut dès le premier tour
expliquez nous pourquoi
écoutez c'est vrai que c'est une action
en justice au caractère inédit puisque
nous avons été vainqueur de cette
élection municipale
mais nous avons décidé de contester
devant le tribunal administratif par la
voix notre avocat maître jean marc
maillot avocat voir montpellier de
contester ce scrutin parce qu'il ya un
problème de sincérité du scrutin tout
simplement commandes et de sincérité
pour quelles raisons bien écouter la
raison est simple
d'abord il faut supposer de questions
pourquoi adam voyez pourquoi nos
gouvernants ont envoyé les citoyens
français dans des bureaux de vote alors
que la veille
ces mêmes dirigeants politiques et ce
gouvernement avait demandé aux citoyens
français de ne plus se rendre dans les
commerces dans les cafés dans les
restaurants dans les boîtes de nuit dans
les écoles qui était le lendemain
transformer un bureau de vote
on a demandé à des citoyens français de
ne plus sortir de chez eux mais en
revanche le gouvernement leur a demandé
de faire un acte citoyenne à la montée
la question que je pose aujourd'hui qui
mérite d'être posée à vomi outre la
faute politique extrêmement grave
avons nous affaire à des zincs hôpital
ce que je pense ou à des irresponsables
qui ont envoyé les électeurs français
aux abattoirs
ça c'est une question qui mérite d'être
analysée aidé à proposer et le moment
venu si jamais de rendre des comptes
en quoi selon vous le rond on entendait
à votre idée hein
mais en quoi selon vous ce que le temps
aura été finalement
on s'insère puisque les gens qui se sont
déplacés au on voté en toute conscience
c'est peut-être au niveau de la
participation 7,5 me pointer du doigt
alors on t'aime a couru effectivement il
ya un gros problème de participation et
j'en suis le prestige principal
responsable puisque j'ai lancé un appel
la veille du scrutin sur les réseaux
sociaux des appels d'amis 15 août
demandé aux électeurs
makoun ils sont 2500 à ne pas se
déplacer elle passera les bureaux de
vote
cet appel il a été largement entendu
puisque effectivement à célébrer son
détonnant le taux d'abstention record au
niveau national
80% des électeurs c'est une vraie joie
ne sont pas déplacés ma liste et la
liste que je conduisais a été élu
puisque bien évidemment avec le mode de
scrutin que vous connaissez il suffisait
d'une seule voix pour être élu mais avec
seulement 17 % des électeurs inscrits
sur les listes électorales
un problème de sincérité du scrutin
c'est la raison pour laquelle cette
action ainsi son caractère inédit mérite
à être mené il faudrait que le fasse
jurisprudence parce que nous faisons
pour le 16 pour la sincérité du scrutin
mais nous faisons également des marches
sur les styles par solidarité avec
toutes les victimes du camp visiteur le
premier tour des élections municipales
alors je ne sais pas si vous l'avez
entendu sur notre antenne en ouverture
de ce journal on a eu un médecin
généraliste docteur legrand qui a eu des
mots assez durs
justement rapport avec ces élections
pointant clairement du doigt une courbe
ascendante des cas de cornas virus
quinze jours après ces élections vous
sur le terrain
est-ce que vous avez constaté peut-être
des mises en danger de la population
lors du vote de risque de contagiosité
pour ce virus
effectivement j'ai un président de
bureau de vote qui était également
candidat journaliste qui était jusque là
ils sont en vie qui a été touchée par le
premier 19 mai j'ai décollé de mères qui
ont perdu l'un des présidents de bureaux
de vote
aucun bus l'avis des militants de partis
politiques certaines communes ont perdu
la vie à cause de ce virus
on a envoyé ces gens à l'abattoir ils
ont aujourd'hui perdu la vie il va
falloir abandonner après cette crise
sanitaire puisque aujourd'hui le
problème il faudrait qu'il faut gérer la
crise sanitaire au niveau de notre pays
mais après la foule a effectivement que
ces gens-là nous rende des comptes
voilà c'est une scène située vie 2
qu'elle serait justement cette forme de
de réclamation si josi auprès du
gouvernement que faudra-t-il faire une
fois la crise passée on vous dit
demander des comptes sous quelle forme
que le fond vous savez je suis pas
juriste mais il y à des commissions
d'enquêté parlementaires et puis il ya
la cour de justice pour les
personnalités vous savez dans cette
affaire-là il ya le gouvernement mais il
ya également ce que je le prends pour
également responsable du maintien de ces
street est le deuxième personnage de
l'état du sénat gérard larcher qui a
incité le président de la république a
maintenu ce pays n'est pas le seul
les principaux dirigeants des partis
politiques français ont également
demandé le maintien cette
aujourd'hui ces gens là marine le pen
le premier fédéral national du parti
socialiste olivier sports monsieur jacob
christian jacob pour les républicains
ils ont demandé le médian du butin
aujourd'hui ces mêmes personnes
on ne les entend plus bien évidemment il
va falloir abandonner que nous donne des
explications et je crois que une fois
que cette épidémie sera passé il faut
absolument que les antennes et qui nous
expliquent pourquoi ils ont privilégié
de la politique politicienne plutôt que
la santé de nos concitoyens alors à
laurent jaoul c'est vrai que manuel
micro edouard fini peut en tout cas le
gouvernement a évoqué le conseil
scientifique
il n'y avait pas selon eux de danger
ce moment-là envoyer les français voter
quelle réponse est un argument de
défense ou même pour le gouvernement
alors je vais vous dire moi ça me fait
rigoler une réponse aux amateurs
christophe castaner a adressé la veille
du scrutin
un courrier à tous les maires de france
dans lequel nous disait que dans le cas
de personnes fragiles depuis de soixante
dix a requis fin les terreurs un certain
nombre de passages pour que ses
électeurs puissent augmenter plus
rapidement
on nous a laissé comprendre par
l'intermédiaire avait pressé que le
contrôle d'identité les brousses faire
assez rapidement et que si ces personnes
fragiles ou qui avait un comportement
suspect qui tous et se prouver avec leur
de vote pour demander d'appeler le samu
alors attendez moi comme ça
extraordinaire de dire qu'il n'y avait
pas de problème
savitri 19 le président de la république
s'est longuement posé la question de
savoir s'il allait devenir le tout
premier tour il a imité le chant des
sirènes parti politique est aujourd'hui
le constat est là et déjà été en danger
et déjà ça c'est un incontestable
merci beaucoup l'orangé ou le maire de
saint-brès dans l'hérault d'avoir été
avec nous on dirait que tu rt france